while president Trump's proposed travel
ban is yet to get off the ground he'll
be hoping to make better progress in one
of his other key pledges that's the
border wall with Mexico
he sent his new secretary for homeland
security on a tour of the southern
frontier that's John Kelly and he's
already said that construction on a wall
between the u.s. and Mexico could be
well underway within two years well dr.
Peter watt is a lecturer in Latin
American politics at the University of
Sheffield and joins me now thank you
very much for joining us let's start
with the wall at construction maybe
within two years say he is only in
office for four is this realistic no
actually there is a wall already exists
in all the urban areas the towns and the
major cities like El Paso between um
Paso and Juarez and San Diego and
Tijuana so the wall already exists and
that came in in 1994 really when Bill
Clinton under operation gatekeeper
started this project of militarizing the
border ken went hand in hand with free
trade policies NAFTA and ironically
while trade was freely crossing the
border made it more and more difficult
for people to cross into the United
States and what it mean meant that was
that people would go to the remote areas
in Arizona for example and tried to
cross through the desert and so the
number of deaths increased by about 500
percent in those first years of migrants
crossing and being exposed to the
elements and there is a wall that
already exists and it's fairly effective
there's about 60,000 Border Patrol
agents already is the largest police
force in the United States and Trump has
talked of adding another 5,000 to that
of course then there's the the you know
the how realistic it is to build a
further wall through those remote areas
which crosses mountain ranges rivers all
kinds of things remember that the border
between the United States and Mexico is
about 2,000 miles long so it kind of
equivalent from going from London to
Cairo so imagine building a wall
all the way across Central Europe and
into North Africa it's not an easy thing
to do
of course it's interesting that as soon
as Trump comes to power
having campaigned about helping working
people and helping poor the first thing
he does is say we're gonna build the
wall and you know his priority is to use
the resources of US taxpayers to build
this kind of impossible wall between the
u.s. and Mexico when you know that over
45 million people living in poverty in
the United States yeah and one of his
other promises was of course to deport
any illegal Mexican immigrants from the
United States and with all the palaver
about his travel ban going on in the
last week it seems to have been sort of
flown under the radar that he has
already started that process in his
homeland security secretary John Kelly
and saying that the u.s. currently is
not rounding anyone up and says that
people that the Immigration and Customs
Enforcement apprehend are people who
were illegal and then some so these
deportations have already started what
have you made of this and the fact that
he is carrying out effectively he's
beginning to get rid of the millions of
people he said he would yeah I mean even
the language he uses you know abhorrent
a racist
nobody is illegal there are people who
are in the United States without the
correct documentation okay but it's I
think you're right it does act as a
distraction from the Muslim travel ban
and so this has been going on all the
time since Trump came to power but of
course it was already in existence so
President Obama actually deported more
undocumented migrants than all previous
US presidents put together so as
president Trump's getting a bit of
unfair stick if President Obama was
deporting the same people so effectively
they will it is very welcome and the
exposure and the press coverage and the
contradictions of his policy is is can
only be a good thing in my view that's
what the press should have been doing
all along initially done
under Obama Obama deported 2.5 million
people between 2009 and 2014 so really
what's happened is the Obama
administration accelerated the
infrastructure and the means by which to
deport undocumented migrants back to
Central America and Mexico and I think
what's happening under Trump is that the
the kind of cozy liberal language has
been removed and you're going to see an
acceleration of this policy and the the
the the entire discourse of Trump and
the administration is that they've taken
the gloves off and they're trying to
normalize as much as possible these very
racist policies and the Muslim ban of
course is part of that but the
deportation program is also you know
further aspect of that dr. Peter walk
from the University of Sheffield thanks
for your time